good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime
i'm rachel campos stuffy
tonight we start by looking at where our
country is heading it's been a
tumultuous two years for america from
covid lockdowns that crippled businesses
and shuttered schools to riots in the
street that led to fear
anger and destroyed livelihoods along
the way
how our children are even being taught
to hate america now
i don't know about you but this is not
the america i grew up with this is not
the nation i remember
but last night
something happened that should leave all
of us with a new hope
all across america voters told democrats
we've had enough
of your marxist race-based agenda
in minneapolis the people overwhelmingly
voted to reject defunding the police
while in deep blue new jersey an
election earthquake shook the garden
state incumbent phil murphy might have
won the race but challenger jack
citarelli
pushed hard to the finish line showing
that no one saw this coming but the most
resounding repudiation of the left
happened in virginia where glenn younkin
shook the political world and won the
virginia governor's race
we were joined by
neighbors and friends of all races of
all religions of all ages of all
political ideologies this is the spirit
of virginia coming together like never
before the spirit of washington and
jefferson and madison and monroe and
patrick henry
a coalition of parents and neighbors
came together to tell terry mcauliffe
and the democrats no more
but of course that's not how the liberal
media saw it i got to get the elitism
out of my party i get i got to get the
the the the moralizing out of my party
but you've got to get some of this
racial dog whistling out of your party
critical race theory isn't taught it
means something different to voters they
think it is so republicans are fixing it
glenn younkin's closing message to
virginia voters has almost singularly
singularly focused on weaponizing race
these republicans are dangerous they're
dangerous to our national security
because stoking that kind of soft white
nationalism
eventually leads to the hardcore stuff
the left continued to play the race card
because that's the only thing they know
how to do
i guess they must have missed
cuban-american jason miatas who was the
first child of an immigrant to be
elected attorney general of virginia
and winsome sears became the first black
woman to win statewide elected office in
virginia
there are some who want to divide us and
we must not let that happen
they would like us to believe we are
back in 1963 when my father came
we have had a black president elected
not once but twice and here
i am living proof
i love it sears is an example of
everything that makes america great
she's an immigrant from jamaica who
served as a marine before starting a
family of her own and then entering
politics to give her own children a
better life and now her success is being
challenged by the likes of joy reid
earlier today the lieutenant
governor-elect fired back
i wish joy reed would invite me on her
show i'm let's see if she's woman enough
to do that she talks about white
supremacy does she know that i ran
against a white supremacist
i mean joy come on get your facts
straight and then come talk to me
remember current virginia governor ralph
northam was featured in this infamous
photo in college featuring blackface and
a kkk hood yet somehow the left wants to
call anyone who disagrees with them
racist including a jamaican-american
immigrant
but these historic victories weren't
about the color of one's skins they were
about the issues like our failing
economy and surging inflation that will
make thanksgiving the most expensive on
record
but most importantly these elections
were about our greatest resource our
children
maybe democrats are starting to realize
they're running on a losing message
democrats are coming across in ways that
we don't recognize
that are annoying
and offensive
and seem out of touch in ways that i
don't think show up in our feeds when
we're looking at
our kind of echo chamber
because even kamala harris knows how
important the virginia election is
every four years when this election
happens for governor of virginia
it's a tight election
it's a close election
and it is a bellwether for what happens
in the rest of the country what happens
in virginia
will in large part determine
what happens in 2022 2024 and on
it's been a hard couple years here in
america but hopefully we're in the home
stretch of the hard times and the people
of virginia and new jersey have shown us
there's reason to be hopeful
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else